FEMALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
everybody.
Thanks for coming out.
My name is [? Marjay. ?]
And for this segment of Authors
at Google, I have the
pleasure of introducing
Jeremy Scahill.
So I had the privilege of
meeting Jeremy at this year's
Sundance Film Festival after
watching the premiere of his
new documentary film "Dirty
Wars," which he
co-wrote and produced.
This talk is pretty timely due
to the US military tactics
being a hot topic in
the news today.
So we've all been really
anticipating his visit with us
to discuss his new book "Dirty
Wars, The World is a
Battlefield."
So I'm going to brag about
Jeremy a little bit here.
So Jeremy Scahill is
a National Security
Correspondent for "The Nation"
magazine and is a Puffin
Foundation Writing Fellow
at the Nation Institute.
Jeremy has reported from around
the world in countries
such as Afghanistan, Somalia,
Iraq, Nigeria, and Yemen.
Jeremy is also author of the
New York Times Best Seller
"Black Water," The Rise of
the World's Most Powerful
Mercenary Army."
Jeremy's courageous work has
sparked several congressional
investigations and won some of
journalism's highest honors.
He was twice awarded the George
Polk Award, in 1998 for
foreign reporting and in 2008
for his book "Blackwater."
I found this quote online
the other day.
And I really think it sums up
Jeremy pretty perfectly.
"There is no journalist in
America who has exposed the
truth about US government
militarism more bravely, more
relentlessly, and more valuably
than Jeremy Scahill."
So that being said, please join
me in welcoming Jeremy
Scahill to Talks at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY SCAHILL: It's really
great to be with all of you.
I use so many Google products
that to actually be here is a
bit surreal.
And I'm hoping that one of you
has access to the servers
because I'd like to permanently
delete some of my
emails from a few years
ago, if someone can
help facilitate that.
I've tried very hard to figure
out how to do it.
So, I guess, come see
me afterwards.
It's also interesting because
in looking at the US drone
program, of course, you almost
never hear any US officials
publicly acknowledge that the US
is engaged in drone bombing
around the world.
And the first time that I'm
aware of that President Obama
actually addressed the issue was
on a Google+ Hangout where
he was asked a question
by a young person
about the drone program.
And he answered it.
And it was at his Hangout that
he did it at the White House,
which is interesting because at
the time they wouldn't talk
to journalists about it.
But then when he did the
Hangout, he talked about it.
So I often joked that the new
way that we declassify
information in our society is
for somehow to have officials
go on Google+ Hangouts or late
night talk shows, which is
primarily how this
administration has discussed
the more covert aspects
of its wars.
I think we're living in a moment
where, I think, we're
going to look back years from
now and realize that there
were things done during the
course of the Obama
administration that ended up
solidifying, as sort of
permanent fixtures of US
national security policy, some
of the worst aspects of what
many people attribute to the
Bush-Cheney era.
And because you have a popular
constitutional law professor,
Nobel Peace Prize winning
Democratic president in office
continuing some of the policies
that many liberals
opposed when they were being
enacted by Bush and Cheney,
the chances of sort
of dismantling the
counter-terrorism apparatus
that's been built up over the
past two administrations is
going to be very unlikely.
I think that we are now in
an area where the Obama
administration has made
assassination a central part
of what is called US national
security policy.
And if McCain had won the
election in '08, I don't
believe for a moment that you
would have been seeing polls
indicating that 70% of
self-identified liberals
support drone strikes and that
support for those strikes
drops only negligibly when the
target in question is an
American citizen.
I think that President Obama
has effectively sold the
concept to liberals, to the
liberal base, that he's waging
a smarter war and a cleaner war
where there are strikes
that are surgically taking out
terrorists that are plotting
against the United States.
And I think that a lot of the
trust that people place in
Obama is going to come back to
haunt us when a Marco Rubio is
in office or a Jeb Bush is in
office and they say, well, you
guys can't say anything to us
because when Obama was doing
it, you were cheering it on.
And I think, in sort of looking
at the five years of
the Obama administration, I've
sort of come to the conclusion
that our real principles, what
we actually believe, is not
tested when someone that we sort
of loathe is in office.
It's easy to be against
Dick Cheney.
And I do sort of imagine him as
this Darth Vader character
in his lair, plotting the
destruction of the world so
that Halliburton stocks
can go up.
But I think that Obama
is different.
I think that President Obama
believes sincerely that he's
engaged in the most effective
way to keep the country safe.
And I certainly disagree
with that conclusion.
And I'm going to talk about some
of the reasons why and
the countries where I've
traveled and sort of how I see
these covert wars unfolding and
the impact that they're
going to have.
But we're not tested when
someone that's easy to hate or
oppose is in office, that's
almost sort of cartoonishly
devilish in his presentation.
Your principles are tested when
someone that you actually
like is in office or that
you may have voted for.
And when you look at the
policies and say, I like this
person as a political leader.
And I'm inspired by him.
But I'm against these
particular policies.
That's what principle is.
It's you don't cede
your conscience
to a political figure.
Then, you're not actually
engaged in fighting for a
better country.
You're ceding your ability to
make decisions or formulate
principles to a partisan
political figure.
Right now, we don't know how
many countries the US is at
war in or at war against.
There are, by some estimates,
US special operations forces
deployed in 75 to 100 countries
around the world.
And that doesn't mean that we
are doing drone strikes there
or cruise missile strikes.
In some cases, there's a very
small covert presence.
And they're doing night raids or
snatching individuals that
are deemed to be threats
or bumping people off.
In some of the countries,
there are drone strikes.
In many of them, the
relationship is that the US is
sending some of its most elite
commandos to embed with or
train or facilitate
the actions of
local government forces.
In places like Yemen, for
instance, the United States
has built up a counter-terrorism
unit there.
And it can become problematic
when you build up these units
with tremendous American
technology and brain power and
then expect that they're going
to be fighting al-Qaeda when
what ends up happening at the
end of the day is that these
elite US trained forces are used
to defend a failing or
flailing regime.
And that certainly happened
in Yemen.
And it sparked tremendous amount
of anger in Yemen that
this elite force that the US
built up of Yemenis to target
al-Qaeda actually was used to
defend the regime when the
Arab Spring was happening.
In Somalia, I went to Mogadishu,
which at the time
was in summer of 2011.
There was incredibly fierce
fighting in Mogadishu.
A militant movement called
al-Shababb was in control of
roughly 50% of the capital, and
by some estimates, 40% to
60% of the rest of Somalia.
And they're fighting against a
network of US funded warlords,
some of whom had actually been
allies of al-Qaeda in an
earlier iteration
in their lives.
And they're now on the US
payroll as sort of proxy
forces to hunt down people that
the US has deemed to be
Islamist radicals or within the
leadership of al-Qaeda in
East Africa or in al-Shabaab.
And there's also a massive
African Union peacekeeping
force primarily made up of
Ugandian and Burundian
soldiers that are funded,
trained, equipped, armed by
the United States.
And when I flew into the
airport, into Aden Adde
International Airport, when we
landed on the ground and we
were taxiing, I noticed this
huge structure that looked to
me like a forward operating
base that you would see in
Afghanistan or Iraq
or elsewhere.
And it appeared to be a
relatively new construction.
And there was basically like a
small village inside of it of
houses and administrative
looking buildings.
And then there were some small
hangars for aircraft.
And when I met up with my Somali
contact, who was going
to take us around Mogadishu
for a couple of weeks and
hopefully keep us alive, I said,
what's that building?
And he said, oh, that's
Guantanamo.
And I say, well, what
do you mean?
He goes, oh, that's where
the Americans are.
We call it Guantanamo.
And I said, well, what
goes on there?
And he said, well, the Americans
are training Somali
forces there.
And then they go out and do
operations in the city.
And to me it was sort
of incredible.
I had never heard of this.
This is under the Obama
administration.
There's this base.
It's the worst kept secret in
Somalia that the Americans
have a base at the airport.
I mean, not the greatest place
to stick a covert base for
counter-terrorism operations.
But nonetheless, there it was.
And I ended up investigating
what goes on at that base and
found Somalis who were liaising
with the CIA.
And they were from the sort
of fragile government that
existed in Mogadishu.
And they were working with
the CIA and US military
intelligence to hunt down and
target the leadership of
al-Shabaab.
And one Somali agent described
to me how the Americans would
line up the Somali operatives
that they were working with in
training and pay them $200 a
month in cash to serve as this
kind of hit force within
the country.
I also discovered that there is
a prison in the basement of
Somalia's US backed and US
funded National Security
Service, which is their main
intelligence service.
And that in the basement of this
prison, there are people
that have been snatched from
other countries in East Africa
and taken there in rendition
flights, some of which have
been directed by the
United States.
So the Obama administration, or
the CIA, will instruct the
Kenyan military or Kenyan secret
police to go and snatch
someone from a neighborhood in
Nairobi and take them to
Wilson Airport and then shackle
them, hood them, and
fly them to Somalia where
they're then put in this
prison and interrogated at
times by US personnel,
intelligence or military
personnel.
And I met a journalist who was
put in that prison for filming
an operation that
the government
didn't want him to film.
And he told me that there were
Americans in there that were
interrogating prisoners.
And then we discovered, we had
smuggled out of that prison
the testimony of a guy who had
been kidnapped in Kenya and
taken to that prison because the
Americans believe that he
had information on one of the
senior leaders of al-Qaeda in
East Africa.
And they took him out of his
home in Kenya, flew him there.
And then he was being
interrogated repeatedly by
American agents.
And the journalists described
the prison to me as infested
with bed bugs, no
natural light.
Prisoners are never
allowed outside.
None of them have access
to lawyers.
In many cases, their family
members don't even know that
they're there, including people
that have been taken
from countries outside
of Somalia.
And I'm telling you this story
because when President Obama
was first elected, he issued a
series of executive orders.
One was to close the US prison
at Guantanamo in Cuba.
Another was to dismantle the
network of secret CIA prisons
in countries like Poland or
Thailand or elsewhere.
And then another was aimed at
ending the practice of torture
or what the Bush-Cheney
administration liked to call
enhanced interrogation
techniques.
And President Obama said that
our interrogation methods are
going to conform to the US Army
Field Manual and that
we're not going to be using
techniques such as water
boarding on prisoners and
putting them in boxes with
insects and other things
that happened under
the Bush-Cheney era.
But what actually has happened
is that the Obama
administration has sort of
tweaked some of the program
and has re-branded it as a sort
of more humane, lawful
approach to counter-terrorism.
So instead of snatching someone
ourselves and putting
them in a CIA Cessna and flying
them to Thailand or
Poland or elsewhere to put them
in a CIA black site, we
are instructing other
governments to abduct the
people for us or snatch or pick
up the people that we
want taken and then to fly them
to a prison that's not
run by the United States.
It's run by something
resembling a
government in Somalia.
And then our intelligence
operatives have access to
these prisoners.
So is it different from
the Bush-Cheney era?
Yes, it is.
It's that they've outsourced
some of the
aspects of the program.
But rendition continues
under Obama.
The use of prisons that are
secret and human rights abuses
are still happening at the
request of the United States
government.
And so I think that the Obama
administration can say, we've
shut down all of these things.
And it's true.
They have.
But they found a way to continue
them through a sort
of backdoor approach.
Now the President has failed to
close Guantanamo, not just
because he hasn't fought
hard enough on it.
Republicans have been
blocking funding.
But one of the results of the
sort of Guantanamo issue
festering, and the fact that
there are 27 people now that
are being forced fed in
Guantanamo that are on hunger
strike, many of the prisoners
have already
been cleared for release.
And the US refuses to release
those individuals.
President Obama doesn't want
to stick more people in
Guantanamo.
Every time they try to prosecute
someone on terrorism
charges in the civilian
courts, the
Republicans go bananas.
They want them treated
as enemy combatants.
They don't want them to have
access to Miranda rights.
So a pattern that we've seen is
that instead of focusing on
capturing these individuals and
trying to bring them to
justice in our civilian court
system, the program has, in
many cases, become just
a kill program.
It used to be kill-capture.
And the capture part of it
resulted in secret prisons and
Guantanamo and military
commissions.
And so it's more convenient and
expedient, in the eyes of
the administration, to just
start killing the people that
the US suspects are plotting
acts of terror against the
United States.
Now, having been in Somalia and
traveled in areas that are
under the control of al-Qaeda
in Yemen and Somalia and
elsewhere, I know first-hand
that there are people plotting
to kill Americans.
These are real plots.
They want to blow up
our airplanes.
They want to poison
water supplies.
They want to set off bombs in
Times Square or elsewhere.
I mean, this is real.
This is not some invented
threat.
I mean, there are dangerous
groups of people that are
plotting these things.
And I believe that, as a nation,
we have a right to
defend ourselves.
So I'm not a pacifist.
But my concern is that in the
pursuit of a relatively small
group of people, who are
plotting against the United
States, we are actually creating
more new enemies than
we are killing actual
terrorists.
I don't know if many of you have
heard of this policy that
has been popularized under
President Obama with the
approach to drones.
But it's called signature
strikes.
And it started in Pakistan and
has now expanded to Yemen.
And to me, it's sort of a
grotesque form of pre-crime.
it's sort of like "Minority
Report" where if you are a
military aged male in a certain
region of Pakistan or
a certain region of Yemen and
you are with a group of other
military aged males and someone
in that group has been
in phone contact with someone
that the United States is
watching as a potential
terrorist or you've visited a
certain building where the
US has been monitoring a
suspected terrorist, they will
create a pattern of life and
preemptively determine that
those people, because of who
they're associated with and
where they reside and the fact
that they're males, that
they are terrorists.
And so when the US kills them,
then they declare them as
terrorists, even when they don't
know the identities of
the people that they're killing
or have any actual
evidence that they're engaged
in terror plots.
And the impact of this on the
ground has been to enrage
tribal leaders and ordinary
people, Bedouin villagers and
others, who don't understand
why the United States is
killing them and the leaders
of al-Qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula are still walking
around as free men.
Said al-Shihri, one of the
leaders of al-Qaeda in the
Arabian peninsula, has been
killed 12 times this year by
the United States.
He was killed a few weeks ago
just before he released a new
audiotape referencing
current events.
And the point I'm making is
the number three guy in
al-Qaeda, we've kill
him a bunch times.
But these guys in Yemen, who
are supposedly the most
dangerous leaders of
the organization,
have not been killed.
And a tremendous number of
civilians have been killed.
So I was hearing from Yemenis,
when I was traveling in these
tribal areas in the South, you
call al-Qaeda terrorism.
We say your drones
are terrorism.
And for them, they're right.
We are the terrorists to them
because they don't understand
the logic of why we're drone
bombing their villages.
Many of these tribes are not
inclined to support al-Qaeda.
Al-Qaeda has been a threat
to them as well.
And they don't want to be at
war with the United States.
It's not in their interest.
It's not in their
tribal interest.
It's not in their national
interest.
And so instead of taking an
approach where we could work
with some of the tribes who
are predisposed to despise
al-Qaeda, we are pushing them
into the fold of if not
supporting al-Qaeda, taking up a
mentality of the enemy of my
enemy is my friend.
And so I started this at the
beginning by saying that I
think that a lot of liberals
believe that Obama's waging a
smarter, cleaner war.
Because on the Google+ Hangout,
Obama said that the
numbers of civilians killed has
been exaggerated and that
it actually is a relatively
small group of people.
Those of us that have been going
to these countries as
journalists and reporting on
it all have come across
stories that are just shocking
in the number of civilians
that have actually
been killed.
And so you can argue that drone
strikes are a smarter
alternative to big military
deployments.
But Obama was never considering
sending
in troops to Yemen.
So it's sort of a false
choice that a lot
of people put forward.
But also, to say that it's a
smarter policy and a more
effective policy and a cleaner
policy without acknowledging
the potential for blowback that
these strikes are causing
is to only tell part
of the story.
And so in order to have an
actual debate in this country
about what a real national
security policy would look
like, we would actually have to
have a full assessment of
who actually has been killed
in the drone strikes.
Because when we're doing
signature strikes and we don't
know who the people are and we
don't have actual evidence
that they're engaged in a real
plot, I think we're ultimately
undermining our own national
security because we're giving
a new generation of people a
legitimate reason to want to
harm Americans.
This is not about our freedom
or our McDonald's.
This is, you killed my family.
And revenge is a very, very
powerful motivator.
And I fear that we are going to
pay for this, if not in the
next few years, sometime
down the line.
One of the things we all have
to-- when we look at the
history of how did 9/11 happen,
if we want to really
face the facts, 9/11 happened
in part as a result of US
foreign policy.
And it was a response to a
widely held perception that
the US was at war against Islam
and that the United
States was an unquestioning
supporter of Israel's
activities in the Middle East
and against the Palestinians.
It was not just some sort of
comic book version of they
hate our freedom.
And I think we don't study
history at our own peril.
We have to learn from
these events.
And I think that the people that
will pay the price for it
are not going to be folks in the
US military or political
leaders in the US.
It's going to be American
tourists somewhere.
Or it's going to be kids
at a sporting event.
And I fear for the impact that
our policies are going to have
down the line.
We really crossed a line, I
think, in this continuation of
the Bush era policies
in late 2011.
There were a series of strikes
that were authorized by
President Obama in Yemen.
One was on September 30, 2011.
And then the other was on
October 14, 2011 where three
US citizens were killed
in drone strikes.
And the main target of the first
drone strike was this
guy named Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
And I'm sure many of you have
seen some clip or something
from his videos that have been
posted on YouTube or elsewhere
where you see this guy with a
big beard with a camouflaged
jacket in front of a black flag
calling for armed jihad
against the United States and
calling on young Muslims in
Western countries to rise up
within their own countries,
whether it's the United States
or Britain, and plot attacks
or to come to Afghanistan or
Yemen or Somalia to join the
fronts of jihad.
Well, Anwar Al-Aulaqi has
a fascinating story.
And it really is part of
the spine of my book.
I got to know his family
very well.
And his father is actually an
extraordinary man, this guy
named Dr. Nasser Al-Aulaqi.
He's an agricultural engineer
and one of the leading people
in Yemen trying to work on the
country's water crisis.
Yemen may be the first country
in the world to completely run
out of water.
And this man has spent his
entire life trying to address
that problem.
And he came to the US, Dr.
Nasser Al-Aulaqi, in 1966 as a
Fulbright scholar.
And he showed me this essay that
he wrote when he was a
young student.
He said in it that he was
mesmerized by the
progressivism of America and
that he wanted to be a part of
it and that he wanted to get an
American education and live
his life according to the
American spirit and then go
back to Yemen and contribute to
improving the lives of his
countrymen.
So he comes here in '66.
And he's studying at New Mexico
State University.
And he ends up getting his
degree very quickly and then
moves on to getting
a Master's degree.
And his wife comes over
and joins him.
And she got her GED in
the United States.
And she was working at a candy
factory to help support her
husband while he getting
his education.
And in 1971, they had their
first child, Anwar Al-Aulaqi,
who was born in Las Cruces,
New Mexico.
And Nasser told me, at the time,
you could smoke cigars
in the hospitals.
And he passed out "It's
a Boy" cigars.
And they really wanted to raise
Anwar as an American.
And they were contemplating
staying in the United States.
And they moved to the Twin
Cities in Minnesota.
And Nasser took a job at
a university there.
And Anwar went to grade school
and went to the YMCA.
And they took trips
to Disneyland.
And his first language
was English.
And when Anwar was seven, the
family moved back to Yemen so
that Nasser could take a job
building up the Department of
Agricultural Engineering
at Sana'a University.
And he did that with millions of
dollars in support from the
US government.
And he worked closely
with USAID.
And Anwar went to a school in
Yemen that was bilingual.
And he went to school with
the elite of the country,
including the children of the
dictator Ali Abdullah Saleh.
Some of his classmates in that
school would go on to be the
people the US worked with to try
to kill Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
He graduates from high school
and then wants to go back to
the US to go to university.
And he goes to Colorado,
just as the Gulf War
was starting in 1991.
And at that time, Anwar
Al-Aulaqi was
not a religious guy.
He was going to study
engineering.
I remember myself, I was 16
when the Gulf War started.
And it was the first time that
I really came face-to-face
with the fact that the US is
engaged in these wars.
And I remember being
actually afraid.
You heard Bernard Shaw on the
phone under a desk for CNN and
Peter Arnett.
And I was shocked that there
was someone actually named
Wolf Blitzer who was reporting
from the Pentagon.
And Al-Aulaqi sort of became
politicized by that war.
And he started doing some
anti-war organizing and was
invited by a local mosque
in Colorado to
come and give a lecture.
And the imam at the mosque was
quite taken with him and said,
you have a real gift
for speech.
I think you should continue
to come back.
And Anwar started to spend more
and more time at this
mosque and decided that he
didn't want to be an engineer
but that he wanted to study
Islam and that he wanted to
become an imam.
And so he began a course of
Islamic scholarship and
ultimately did become an imam.
And while in Denver, Colorado,
his eldest son was born,
Abdulrahman, in 1995.
And so Anwar and his family
are in Denver.
Then they moved to San Diego.
And he's an imam at a
mosque in San Diego.
And when 9/11 happened, Anwar
Al-Aulaqi was the imam at a
large Islamic center in Falls
Church, Virginia called the
Dar Al-Hijrah Mosque.
And I remember Al-Aulaqi after
9/11 because I was working as
a radio producer.
And I remember seeing him on PBS
and hearing him on NPR and
reading about him in "The
Washington Post."
Al-Aulaqi was a very public
figure after 9/11 and was much
in demand in the corporate media
because he was helping
to make sense of the experience
that, I think, was
common among many American
Muslims where you were
horrified at the attacks, wanted
justice, like I think
all of us did, and those who
did it to be brought to
justice, but also facing this
intense hatred and bigotry.
And Muslim businesses were being
attacked, taxi drivers,
non-Muslims who people thought
were Muslims, like Sikhs and
others, were being attacked.
There was this real--
I'm sure we all remember it,
this real climate of fear.
And the day after September
11, a woman stumbled into
Al-Aulaqi's mosque, a Muslim
women, after being attacked
with a baseball bat.
And Muslim organizations and
charities were being raided.
The FBI was putting pressure on
imams to become informants
for the government.
All of this was playing out.
And Al-Aulaqi was a prolific
speaker and
commentator in the media.
And he balanced these
two worlds.
And he said the United States
has a right to go into
Afghanistan and get
those responsible
for the 9/11 attacks.
And he said that the fact that
US policy, pro-Israeli policy
or what the United States had
done in Iraq during the '90s
with its economic sanctions and
the deaths that it caused,
that none of that justifies the
killing of one US civilian
in New York or at
the Pentagon.
And he said this
very publicly.
And you can go back and find
some of his speeches.
In fact, he was considered to
be such a part of mainstream
American dialogue at the time
that he was invited by the
Pentagon to come and speak at
a luncheon on the state of
Islam in the world today.
And he, in fact, did go and
deliver a lecture at the
Pentagon shortly after 9/11.
And we got the documents
on his visit.
And I mentioned this
in the book.
You can tell how bad the US
intelligence was at the time
because among the things they
served was a bacon sandwich at
the event that day when they
invite an imam to come and
speak at the Pentagon and serve
bacon sandwiches, one of
the only, I guess, humorous
moments in my book.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY SCAHILL: But what ended
up happening is that Al-Aulaqi
was very much radicalized by the
US wars, by the invasion
of Iraq, by the images that came
out of Abu Ghraib, and
the use of the Guantanamo
prison.
And his sermons started to
become sharper and sharper.
And he ultimately leaves
the United States and
goes back to Yemen.
And he is recording these
audio messages.
And they're becoming very
popular among young Muslims
around the world.
And his tapes start to pop
up in a number of terror
investigations in Britain,
in the US, and Canada.
And US intelligence is becoming
concerned, not that
Al-Aulaqi is directly involved
with plots, but that his
message, his words, are
inspiring lone wolf terrorists
or small cells of maybe
unaffiliated potential
terrorists to attack public
transportation sites in the UK
or in the US.
And they first have Al-Aulaqi on
their radar in 2005, 2006.
In '06, Al-Aulaqi is in Yemen
in Sana'a, living with his
family and his father's
family.
And he's taking classes.
And he's recording sermons.
And then one day, he is abducted
by Yemen's US trained
counter-terrorism force
and the secret police.
And they stick Anwar Al-Aulaqi
in prison for 18 months.
And 17 of them he spends in
solitary confinement.
And he believed that the United
States was responsible
for his imprisonment.
And when the United Nations
investigated it, they said
that his detention
was extralegal.
And I found out through my
reporting that Al-Aulaqi was
in fact in prison at the
direction of John Negroponte,
who at the time was the
director of national
intelligence and knows a lot
about dirty wars from his time
in Central America in the '80s
when he was a major figure in
facilitating support for the
contra death squads in
Nicaragua and Battalion
316 in Honduras.
But Negroponte met with a
Yemeni official and with
Bandar Bush, the famed Saudi
diplomat whose nickname is
Bandar Bush because he's so
close to the Bush family, and
said that the position of the US
is that they want Al-Aulaqi
kept in prison in Yemen for
four or five years so that
people forget about him and
that he's not able to keep
recording these sermons.
And I reviewed Al-Aulaqi's
prison writings.
And they gave him very
few books in prison.
He hated Shakespeare, thought
Shakespeare was an
imperialist.
He loved Dickens and would
compare figures in the US
government or the Yemeni
government to Uriah Heep and
other characters.
But he also started to read the
literature of very radical
Islamic thinkers or scholars,
including some of the people
that were the framers of the
concept that bin Laden used as
an inspiration to
form al-Qaeda.
And he ends up being released
from prison after 18 months
because of pressure from legal
organizations in Yemen and his
tribe, which is very powerful,
the Awlaki tribe, in Yemen.
So he's forced to be released
by the Yemeni government
because of the political
pressure within the country.
And he comes out of prison
a changed man.
He's fully blown radical.
And he starts a blog called
Imam Anwar's Blog.
And the internet becomes
his mosque.
And he starts to celebrate
attacks against US forces in
various countries and engages
in discussions about whether
suicide bombing is permissible
under Islamic
teachings in the Quran.
And ultimately, he comes out
on the side that suicide
bombings are acceptable
in war.
And the US wants
him shut down.
They're pressuring the Yemeni
government to re-arrest him.
The house is being surveilled.
And Al-Aulaqi decides that he's
going to go underground.
So he leaves the capital of
Sana'a, goes to Shabwah
province in southern Yemen,
where his family is originally
from, and he continues to record
his sermons there.
The head of Yemen's intelligence
agency comes to
Dr. Nasser Al-Aulaqi, who's
a very esteemed
figure in Yemeni society.
And they say, look Nasser, if
you don't get Anwar to come
back to Sana'a and go back into
the prison, the Americans
are going to kill him
with a drone.
This was in April, May, 2009.
And so Nasser, not wanting his
son to be killed and feeling
like there's no evidence that
he's doing anything-- yes,
he's engaged in this
radical speech.
But my son's not a terrorist.
He's just a guy who's views on
the world I don't share.
But I respect his freedom
of speech.
He goes down to meet with his
son and says, they're going to
kill you if you don't come
back and go to prison.
And Anwar sort of angrily says
to his father, what?
Are you working for
the Americans now?
I'm not going to let them tell
me which way to put my bed
when I sleep at night.
I was born free.
I'm going to die free.
And that was the last
conversation that his father
had with him.
So Nasser goes back.
And he's raising
Anwar's family.
There is these three kids,
including the eldest son, who
was born in Denver, Colorado.
And Anwar is underground.
The US starts to hunt for him.
The first time that the US
tried to kill him was in
December of 2009.
And what really sealed
Al-Aulaqi's fate was when
Major Nidal Hasan shot up and
massacred more than a dozen of
his fellow soldiers in Fort
Hood, Texas, if you remember,
in November 2009.
And it emerged that Al-Aulaqi
had been in email touch with
Nidal Hasan.
And to this day, the story
persists that Al-Aulaqi had
something to do with the
Fort Hood massacre.
But the emails have now
been declassified.
And if you read them--
US intelligence, by the way,
believed that he did not have
anything to do with the
Fort Hood massacre.
But if you look at the
declassified emails, Nidal
Hasan was almost like a creepy
stalker and was sending
Al-Aulaqi these notes saying,
I want to give
you a prize of $5,000.
I want to have an essay
contest in your name.
At one point, he asks Al-Aulaqi
to help him find a
Yemeni bride.
And Al-Aulaqi is like,
yeah, I'll keep an
eye out for a brother.
But he basically is sort of
batting him away and treating
him kind of like a stalker.
And Hasan has an interesting
story that
often doesn't get told.
He was an Army psychiatrist
who had been interviewing
Afghan and Iraq war vets.
And he actually tried to have
some of them prosecuted for
war crimes up his chain of
command for the things that
they had told him during their
therapy sessions and was
clearly a guy that was on
a path toward doing
something like this.
But Al-Aulaqi, it seems, did not
have anything to do with
the attack.
But the fact that he had
been in email touch
with him became relevant.
And then the day after the Fort
Hood massacre, Al-Aulaqi
posted a blog post that said
Nidal Hasan is a hero and
called on other Muslims in the
military to do the same thing
that Nidal Hasan had done.
And that's when the campaign to
try to kill Anwar Al-Aulaqi
just intensified.
Then when the underwear
bomber happened.
This deranged young Nigerian
guy, Umar Farouk
Abdulmutallab, tried to bring
down the US airplane by
setting his underpants on fire
on Christmas Day 2009.
After that, it turned out that
Al-Aulaqi had been in
contact with him.
And Al-Aulaqi at one point
said he was my student.
But I didn't direct
him to do that.
But I know him.
And I support what he did.
And so from December of 2009
until September of 2011, by my
count, the US tried to kill
Anwar Al-Aulaqi more than a
dozen times.
And there were several very near
misses, some of which are
sort of like out of a spy
movie where they have
Al-Aulaqi's vehicle.
They're tracking it
in the desert.
They shoot a hellfire missile
from a predator drone.
It misses.
Al-Aulaqi calls for backup.
There's a smoke dust up.
These guys come to
pick him up.
They switch vehicles and drive
off in different directions.
And the CIA ends up blowing
up the guys that
come to rescue him.
And Al-Aulaqi gets away.
And so there's this intense
hunt for him going on.
And behind the scenes, there's
this incredible story.
And I tell it in my book.
While the US is hunting
Al-Aulaqi, this Danish guy
named Morten Strom, also known
as Murad Storm, which is sort
of an amazing name given what
I'm about to tell you.
He goes to the Danish
intelligence service, the PET,
and he says, the Americans are
looking for Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
I can help you find him.
He's like, I was an old friend
of Al-Aulaqi's back in Yemen.
We were in school together.
And we were close.
And Morten Storm was a former
motorcycle gangster with a
long criminal record who
converted to Islam and was
sort of an aspiring jihadist.
And he had gotten to
know Al-Aulaqi in
Yemen in 2004, 2005.
And so Storm goes to the Danish
intelligence and says,
I can help you.
The Danish intelligence service
then calls in the CIA.
And the CIA, Danish
intelligence, and this guy
Morten Storm concoct a plot to
find Anwar Al-Aulaqi a new
wife to have while
he's underground.
And Morten Storm emails
Al-Aulaqi in encrypted emails
and says he wants to help
him find a wife.
And Al-Aulaqi agrees and
wants to do this.
So they literally put an ad
on Facebook for a wife.
And it's like Jihadist OK
Cupid or something.
So they put an add
on Facebook.
And they get all these
responses from women.
And this young woman from
Croatia, who was a Catholic
who converted to Islam named
Aminah, ends up being selected
as the wife.
Now, she has no idea that she's
part of a CIA plot.
She thinks she's going to marry
Anwar Al-Aulaqi and
says, I'm prepared to die.
And I want to marry you.
And Al-Aulaqi and Aminah
exchange these
videos back and forth.
And the videos have now
been made public.
And you can see they're sort
of like Skype dating or
something for a while.
And eventually she says, yes,
I'm going to go and marry him.
And so the CIA paid
for everything.
They buy her plane ticket.
They bought her luggage that
had tracking devices in it.
And the plan was that she's
going to fly to Yemen with the
CIA tracking device Louis
Vuitton bags.
And then she's going to go meet
up with Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
And the US is going to kill
both of them in a drone
strike, which there's such a
morally reprehensible aspect
to that story.
I mean, this woman didn't
know that she was being
used in this way.
But sort of the tables turned
when she arrives in Yemen.
And Al-Aulaqi's guys go to pick
her up at the airport.
And they force her to ditch the
bags and her clothes and
give her new clothes.
So the bags and clothes that
the CIA provided for her
remain in Sana'a.
And she disappears into the
wilderness of Yemen and
actually marries Anwar
Al-Aulaqi and has
a child with him.
So it's like the CIA's
dating service.
They found this bride
for Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
And she's still alive
to this day.
I think she writes for "Inspire"
magazine, which is
the publication of al-Qaeda
in the Arabian Peninsula.
But eventually the US finds
Anwar Al-Aulaqi in
September of 2011.
And they've located him
in the north of Yemen.
They had been looking all
in the south of Yemen.
They find him.
He's in the north of Yemen.
And he's with another American
citizen, this
Pakistani-American named Samir
Khan, who was basically like a
propagandist for jihadist
causes around the world.
And Samir Khan's family,
I got to know them.
And they had been told by the
FBI that there's no charges
against Samir Khan.
But they're very concerned
about what
he's up to in Yemen.
They wanted him to come home.
And he'd found his way to Anwar
Al-Aulaqi and was sort
of like his assistant
or something.
So these guys are in
this house the CIA
is monitoring it.
And they're watching through
the satellites.
And they're waiting for
President Obama to sign off on
the hit against Anwar
Al-Aulaqi.
This was a big deal in the White
House because this was
the first time that
they were going to
assassinate a US citizen.
Assassinate is my word,
not there's.
They call it targeted killing
or liquidating the enemy.
But it is assassination.
So the US is contemplating it.
And Obama ultimately says, I
want to take him out and
becomes prosecutor,
judge, jury, and
executioner of Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
While they're monitoring that
house and these discussions
are going on, Al-Aulaqi's eldest
son, Abdulrahman, who
hasn't seen his father in years
and is a totally normal
teenager living with his
grandparents in Sana'a and
likes hip hop music, goes to
the square with the young
nonviolent revolutionaries, and
was really close to his
younger siblings.
And I got deep into
who that kid is.
And I know that he wasn't
involved with anything vaguely
resembling terrorism and that
he wasn't in any touch with
his father.
A few days after he turned 16,
he sneaks into his mother's
bedroom one morning and steals
$40 from her purse, the
equivalent of $40
in Yemeni rials.
And then he climbs out the
window of the kitchen and goes
to the bus station in Bab al
Yemen, in the old city in
Sana'a, and takes a bus
to Shabwah, where he
thinks his father is.
And his idea is to try to ask
around and see if anyone can
find him because he wants
to speak to his father.
He wants to see his father.
And he felt like turning 16 was
a moment where he was a
man and could go and do this.
And he had a very different
recollection of who his dad
was and sees reports of his
father being compared to Osama
bin Laden and is this
great terrorist.
And so the kid runs away
to look for his dad.
And while he's in Shabwah,
looking for his father, his
father is killed hundreds
of miles away in
the north of Yemen.
And so the grandparents call
him, who are effectively his
parents at this point, and they
said, Abdulrahman, you
have to come home.
Your father's dead.
And at the time, there was
a revolution in Yemen.
And there was fighting in that
part of the country.
And the roads were blocked.
And he had to stay.
He couldn't go back.
So he had to stay for
a couple of weeks.
And so on October 14, 2011, he's
out at dinner with his
cousin Ahmed, who is 17, and a
bunch of other young people
from the tribe.
And a drone appears above them
and launches a missile and
blows them up, killing
this kid and a
group of other teenagers.
And you had three US citizens
that were killed in a two week
period in these operations
authorized by the President.
The killing of Anwar Al-Aulaqi,
I think, was a
turning point.
But I understand why the
US wanted to kill him.
And his family understands why
the US wanted to kill him.
And there was nothing but
praise from Washington,
Democrats and Republicans
alike, for
killing Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
And almost no one seemed
concerned about the fact that
we had just killed a US citizen
who had never been
charged with a crime, who the
United States had never sought
to extradite, never presented
any public evidence against
him, killed him without
any trial.
And he was not on a battlefield
shooting at US soldiers.
To me, it was a significant
moment in our history.
We can debate what we
think about that
strategically or legally.
But I believe it was
significant, particularly
because a popular constitutional
law professor,
Nobel Peace Prize winning
president was the one that
authorized it.
But then the two weeks later,
the killing of this kid, the
White House has never explained
why Abdulrahman
Al-Aulaqi was killed.
I've spent months and months of
my life working on trying
to get an answer.
At one point, a US military
official leaked to the press
that he was actually
21 years old.
Well, then we went and got his
birth certificate from the
state of Colorado.
He had just turned 16, as
the family alleged.
Then they said, well, he was
at an al-Qaeda meeting.
And yet, they couldn't produce
a single name of someone from
al-Qaeda that they killed
at this meeting.
And then they said, well, he
was meeting with this guy,
Ibrahim al-Bana, who was a
propagandist for al-Qaeda in
the Arabian Peninsula.
And then it turns out Ibrahim
al-Bana is still alive and
wasn't there.
So why was this kid killed?
I recently met a former senior
official of the Obama
administration who told me that
when President Obama had
been briefed on that strike, the
one that killed this kid,
that he had been told by the CIA
and military intelligence
that Ibrahim al-Bana
was there alone.
And no one mentioned
anything about the
Al-Aulaqi kid being there.
And this former official told me
that Brennan, John Brennan,
who at the time was the senior
counter-terrorism adviser and
is now the CIA director, that
Brennan believed that it was
an intentional hit on the kid
and ordered a review.
And that review, I tried to
inquire with the White House
and the National Security
Council, to my knowledge has
never been published.
So the official that told me all
of this said to me, look,
I assure you.
This was just a mistake.
It's just a mistake.
It was collateral damage.
And I said, well, if you have
evidence to that effect and
that's true, why not
just say it?
Because it really does seem
like an impossible
coincidence.
And I say at one point in our
film, it's like a tale from
Greek mythology.
You kill the father
and then the son.
And at the end of the day, we
don't know why he was killed.
But I asked this official, why
don't you just say, if it's
collateral damage, that
that's what it was?
And if you did kill someone that
you think was plotting
against the United States, then
say it so that at least
that family knows.
And I think also the American
people have a right to know.
This is serious business when
you're drone striking American
teenagers that have never been
charged with anything.
And if it's just because his
last name is Al-Aulaqi, then
that's just stunning.
So he's assuring me all this.
And he said, well, look.
Look at it this way--
this is a former senior
White House official--
we had just killed three US
citizens in a two week period,
two of whom weren't
even targets.
It didn't look good.
It was embarrassing.
That was his answer.
I mean, that to me, is just
sort of shocking.
When Robert Gibbs, who's the
former White House press
secretary, was asked during the
2012 election campaign,
when he was serving as a senior
surrogate for President
Obama, he was his major
spokesperson.
He was asked by this young
reporter named Sierra Adamson
about the killing of Abdulrahman
Al-Aulaqi.
And you know what Gibbs said?
He said, he should have had
a more responsible father.
There are few things in history
more shameful than
blaming the death of a child
on who their parents were.
And you can go and see that.
It's on YouTube.
And it's gone all around.
He should be ashamed of himself
for saying that.
Harry Reid, the Senate Majority
Leader, was on CNN
after that killing and was asked
about the killings of
Anwar Al-Aulaqi, Samir Khan,
and Abdulrahman Al-Aulaqi.
And Harry Reid said to Candy
Crowley, I do know this.
If there were three Americans
that deserved to be killed, it
was those three.
And I tried to get Harry Reid's
office to comment.
I said, are you really saying
that this 16-year-old kid
needed to be killed?
What evidence do you have he
was involved with anything
threatening the United States?
And they wouldn't answer.
And then I went after
them on Twitter.
And then they blocked me.
And there was no--
it was a badge of pride that I
was blocked by Harry Reid.
So it's mystifying to me that we
don't have an answer on who
killed this kid.
And I think that we're going to
look back on this moment in
time and realize that a lot of
us were asleep at the wheel
and weren't really being
responsible citizens because
we just kind of trusted that
Obama was going to do the
right thing.
And I imagine Darth Vader Cheney
fly fishing somewhere
and kind of having a good
chuckle about this and saying,
it's a good thing that Obama
cleaned this up for every one.
Because now these policies can
continue when Rubio or Jeb
Bush or whoever is going to
come back into power.
And I think that a big part of
our problem as a society is
that we don't see people in
Yemen or Pakistan or Somalia
as human beings whose stories
are worthy of being told or
demanding our attention.
And I think if we had empathy,
if we saw them as equals and
that our lives are not worth
more than them, I think it
would be a lot harder to have
these policies continue.
I think we'd have
a more rigorous
debate in our society.
I watched the Boston Marathon
bombing aftermath just with my
jaw on the floor at how terrible
the media coverage
was and the smearing and tarring
of the reputation of
that young high school track kid
who Rupert Murdoch put his
picture on the "New York Post"
and said, Bag man, these are
who the Feds are looking for.
And this high school track
runner, it's shocking that he
actually went to the marathon
because he liked to run and
wanted to watch the marathon.
And somehow, because he had
brown skin, he becomes a
suspect in this in the eyes of
one of the most powerful media
moguls in history.
And there's so much
misinformation.
And there's just this rush
to judgment always.
When Oklahoma City was bombed,
the first thing was, it's got
to be Islamic radicals
that did this.
And the hysteria around
this also.
And I don't know the motivations
of the people that
did this bombing.
I mean, the story of the
Tsarnaev guys, I want to see
it all play out in court.
I want to know the evidence.
And I want whoever did this
to be brought to justice,
whatever their motivation was.
But I also want to understand
why they did it because I
think that's important.
But there was a part of the
media coverage that was
remarkable.
And that is the stories of the
heroes that responded to the
bombing, like this guy Carlos
Arredondo, who ran toward the
blast after it happened.
And his son had been killed
in Iraq as a soldier.
And Carlos Arredondo,
I know him.
He's a brilliant guy and a brave
man and a noble citizen.
And he runs toward the blast.
And there's that iconic
picture of him.
I'm sure all of you have
seen it where he has
the cowboy hat on.
And he's running the
double amputee--
a guy, both of his legs
are blown off.
And he's trying to
save his life.
And he's tying his leg to try
to stop the bleeding.
And watching Carlos Arredondo
talk about this and also
knowing that he has lost so
much in his own life, it's
just this remarkable human story
that I think all of us
can relate to and say, that's
an amazing person.
And then we had the story of the
kid, the 8-year old kid,
and that beautiful painting
that he did that
went viral on Facebook.
And we know his story and
what is dreams were.
And the Chinese graduate
student, I was with a friend
from China recently when I was
giving a talk in Boston.
And it was right after the
Boston Marathon bombing.
And this friend from China said,
you know, when President
Obama said her name, the name of
this Chinese woman who was
a graduate student in the US,
there was a blog post that
went viral in China.
And the title of it was "Where
You Die Matters."
And the point of it was that if
she had died in a factory
explosion making iPhones for
Americans, her name wouldn't
have been mentioned by the most
powerful man on the planet.
But because she died in Boston,
her life mattered.
And that struck me as sort of
profound because if you think
about the reason why we have
the response to the school
shootings--
and I was devastated when the
"New York Times" put the list
of all of the kids killed
at Newtown.
And you just saw five
years old, six years
old, six years old.
I mean, you can't not cry when
you actually internalize it
because you think, what
if that was my child?
And in thinking about it, I've
spent so much time in
Afghanistan and Somalia
and Yemen.
And I have these faces of kids
that I've met there.
And their parents
were blown up.
Or some of them have been maimed
in a missile strike.
Or they're orphaned.
Or I've met women whose entire
families have been killed.
And I wonder, what if we
knew their stories?
What if we knew that little
girl who was killed in a
bombing in December of '09 in
a US cruise missile strike?
What if we saw the picture that
she had painted or knew
the dream that she had?
Well, then it doesn't become
collateral damage in a strike
aimed at killing dangerous
terrorists.
Then it becomes real people
that we relate to.
The reason why these school
shootings strike us so hard is
that we feel it as though
it's our own people.
But we should extend that right
also to the people that
live on the other side of the
missiles that are being
launched from our country.
The last thing I'll say is last
night I did an event at
the Commonwealth Club
in San Francisco.
And they always ask at the end
of it for a 60 second idea to
change the world.
And I had forgotten that I was
supposed to come up with
something ahead of time.
And I had forgotten.
But what I ended up saying
was, I don't know that it
would change the world.
But I think it would be an
important exercise for all of
us to engage.
And then I realize that part
of why I do this is because
I've long been engaged with
this, and it really has
changed the way I see the world,
is if we all adopt the
story of someone who has either
lost their lives or
lost something deep as a result
of our wars and to know
their story.
So that when we're talking about
it and we say we defend
the drone strikes, that we also
can talk fluently about a
case where it went wrong or
about a case where the death
of someone could potentially
come back to inspire new
enemies to want to attack us.
Because if we have empathy--
only through empathy can you
actually care about someone
enough to stand up and say,
I'm not going to let that
happen to them.
Or I don't want that
to happen anymore.
It's why so many Americans now
are paying attention to the
gun debate is because we don't
want this to happen ever again
in our schools.
And so I think our challenge
really is all of us are busy.
And a lot of people in this
country are struggling.
And it's a hard ask to say to
a single mother in Tennessee
who's struggling to put food
on the table for her kids,
care about what goes
on in Yemen.
People are struggling here.
And I know that.
But I think that for those of
us that have the luxury of
some free time in our life, that
the least we could do is
to actually personalize
these wars.
It shouldn't just be families
with loved ones in the
military that have to pay
attention to what's happening
in Afghanistan.
We're paying for it.
We're paying for
it financially.
And we're paying
for it morally.
And I think that if we ignore
the potential impact of these
policies, we do it
at our own peril.
I have much more faith in my
fellow country people than I
do in the jokers on
Capitol Hill.
And I think that if we start a
hearts and minds campaign in
our own country, to actually
realize who's being killed and
who's not being killed,
who are we
actually targeting here?
Are we safer or less safe
because of the drone strikes
policy and the signature
strike policy?
What would an actual national
security policy look like?
This should be all
of our business.
And with that, I thank
you for your time.
I'm happy to answer any
questions or hear any comments.
It's really an honor
to be with you.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, I want to thank
you for so many thought
provoking observations
and ideas.
One idea that I would like to
ask you to answer maybe a
little bit more.
And I say this because I'm
conflicted about it.
I don't know the answer.
You clearly thought about
a lot more than I have.
Why does it matter or does it
matter that Al-Aulaqi, the
father, was a citizen
of America?
Does that make it worse that
we assassinated him?
Because your empathy argument
suggests that actually it
doesn't matter.
We shouldn't have assassinated
anybody.
JEREMY SCAHILL: I'm glad
that you asked that.
And I often do try to
make the point.
I mean, on a moral level,
there should not be any
difference between how we view
the rights of citizens and
non-citizens to not be killed
in a drone strike,
particularly if they haven't had
any actual charges against
them or there isn't evidence
to prove that they are
involved with the plots
that we say they are.
The reason why I raise the
Al-Aulaqi issue is that I
think there's another dimension
to this that cuts to
the heart of who we
are as a society.
And how we treat the most
reprehensible of our citizens,
I think, speaks volumes
to who--
I'm more concerned with who we
are than who Al-Aulaqi was.
And if in some cases, like
with Dzhokhar Tsarnaev in
Boston, the Republicans said,
we want him treated as an
enemy combatant.
And some said, we want him
shipped to Guantanamo.
And in defending the Al-Aulaqi
thing, they say, well, he
didn't have actual rights
to due process
because he was a terrorist.
And that's the line on it.
To me, if we're going to allow
the mob to grab the pitchforks
and torches and go and deliver
citizens justice in certain
cases, then we should stop
saying that we're a nation
based on the rule of law and
that there are certain
circumstances where the
mob is allowed to
sort of enforce justice.
And we don't actually need
to abide by our own laws.
And I think that if you allow
that line to be crossed and
this happens to our own
citizens, then I think that
there is a serious
constitutional crisis.
I, unfortunately, agreed with
Rand Paul, I wish there was a
more credible person that had
done this in the Senate, when
he was raising some legitimate
questions.
There was also a lot of
craziness that day when he did
the filibuster.
But he raised some legitimate
questions.
But on a moral level, I don't
think there's any difference
whatsoever between doing this
to an American or a
non-American.
You have a response.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's not a
response so much but just to
make sure I understand things
a little bit better.
So you're saying, specifically
in this case, you want to see
us following our own laws.
And that is an important
aspect of the argument.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Yeah,
I think--
AUDIENCE: Other than
the fact that he
was an American citizen.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Oh
yeah, right.
I mean, this is a bigger
picture idea.
But I think that we should
demilitarize our response to
terrorism and view it as a crime
and view terror plots as
crimes not acts of war.
I mean, I think that we have a
robust justice system in this
country that has been the only
vehicle for actually bringing
people to justice is when
they're tried in
the civilian system.
Guantanamo has been a
catastrophic disaster.
I believe that our society would
be stronger if Anwar
Al-Aulaqi had been charged
and indicted and
his extradition demanded.
And if we can't get him after
having done all of that, then
the US has all sorts of options,
some of which would
be military in nature.
But to just skip right to the
death penalty before even
indicting someone, I think
that's something we have to be
really nervous about
in our society.
I think it would have been
much wiser for the US to
charge Anwar Al-Aulaqi.
And I think he potentially could
have been put on trial.
I think that there would have
been an incentive for people
to give him up.
And others might debate that.
But I know that tribe well.
They would have given them up,
I believe, if the US put
pressure on them or figured
out a way to make it worth
their while.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like a
large part of your argument is
a pragmatic one that we're
creating more terrorists by
killing, accidentally or
negligently, some civilians.
And I was wondering if you
could talk about how that
played out when the US was
involved militarily in Central
and South America in the
'70s, '80s, and so on.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Could
you rephrase it?
So you're asking the--
AUDIENCE: I'm asking about
the blowback that the CIA
involvement in Central and South
America had and how that
changes your opinion about the
blowback that we might
experience as a result
of drone strikes.
JEREMY SCAHILL: I think the
legacy of what the US did in
the '70s, '80s in Central
America is still
felt to this day.
Right now there's the trial of
Rios Montt in Guatemala.
And the US was supporting
these murderous juntas.
And the people have spent
decades trying to get justice
for what had been lost in the
contra death squads in
Nicaragua and Battalion
316 in Honduras.
I think it really sparked a lot
of anti-American hatred.
Whether or not there was
specific blowback from that, I
don't know in terms of Americans
being attacked
inside of the United States.
I also think that there was a
different mentality in those
countries then there is in a lot
of Muslim countries around
the world in terms of
the way that the
wars are being fueled.
The US in Central America
was primarily
working with proxies.
And with the exception of the
mining of the Nicaraguan
harbor, where the US had a
guilty verdict against it at
the World Court for having done
that, the US tried to use
proxy forces and more
covert presence.
I think the drones are a great
recruiting tool for al-Qaeda
or other militant organizations
because it's
very good branding.
And so I do fear that we are
giving the perception that
we're at war with Islam.
And I think that that is really
just very, very dangerous.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jeremy.
Thank you for coming.
A very quick technical question,
when you mentioned
Aminah was a covert from the
Catholic to Islam, where did
you get that information?
JEREMY SCAHILL: I read
Serbo-Croatian.
Actually, I can speak
And there was extensive coverage
in the Croatian media
about who she is and very, very,
very technical details
about her life and her work and
her conversion to Islam.
AUDIENCE: I read too.
So maybe you can tell me later
on which publication that was.
Thanks.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Yeah, yeah,
there were a number of exposes
about her in the local
press in Croatia.
And in Serbia, there were some
reporting on it as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
You answered half of the first
one was you consider the
alternatives.
And the alternatives you
suggested were to bring him
here to face our civil
justice system.
But there may be something else
because that seems to me
like a very steep battle to
fight or disadvantageous
battle to fight when you've got
some compelling evidence
to bring against them.
And the second one is, as I
travel through Middle East,
what I see is America
gets the blame and
this unjustified blame.
Really what happens is they see
the United States as an
oppressor when it's really their
own government that's an
oppressor because the foreign
aid that gets there is
somewhat diffused.
It's siphoned off by
the people that
are powers that be.
And there doesn't seem to be any
correction for that type
of activity.
And that's essentially
what's spawning--
in my opinion, that's
what spawns this
anti-American sentiment.
JEREMY SCAHILL: I
agree with you.
I mean, I don't necessarily
agree with saying that that's
the actual thing and that it
has nothing to do with the
US's actions.
But I agree strongly with your
sentiment that these regimes--
the overthrow of Mubarak in
Egypt, for instance, he was a
widely despised man for what he
had done to his own people.
But people are also aware that
he stayed in power in part
because of his tremendous
support from the United States
through successive
administrations.
And we've given a lot of
military aid to the
Jordanians, to the Egyptians, at
times we worked with Bashar
al-Assad in Syria when it was
convenient for us, the Saudis,
the Yemenis.
And I think that it's
a double punch.
I think people perceive the
United States as being on the
side of these dictatorships
and not on the side of
ordinary people.
I've certainly heard that in the
countries that I've been
talking about today.
But I do think though that the
US has a long, or I know that
the US has a long track record
of bolstering these
dictatorships, the Bahraini
regime, the Saudis.
I mean, we are a big part
of that problem.
But I do think that those
regimes deserve their fair
share of the blame for what
they've been involved with.
AUDIENCE: One last thing, US
presence in the Gulf in the
Middle East during the Iran-Iraq
War was a huge
stabilizing factor
in the region.
And as you start to withdraw,
there's all sorts of upheaval
going on over there.
So there seems to be
consequences no matter going
forward or going in reverse.
There appear to be consequences
either way.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Well, I
have a little bit--
you and I could have
a debate club here.
I have a little bit of a
different take on the
Iran-Iraq thing.
Kissinger famously said, we
should arm them both so they
can kill each other off.
I think we were a highly
destabilizing presence,
particularly in Iraq.
The US was supporting Saddam
Hussein in the '80s when he
was at his most brutal.
And Donald Rumsfeld went over
as an envoy in '83 and gave
Saddam golden cowboy spurs,
a gift from Ronald Reagan.
And they removed the Iraqi
government from the list of
state sponsors of terrorism so
that they could sell them
weapons that were then used to
use chemical weapons on the
Kurdish population in
the north of Iraq.
And I think that you can jump in
to history midway and then
say, well, the US
was stabilizing.
And the US was a big part of
creating that or making that
war possible, the
Iran-Iraq War.
AUDIENCE: I sort of agree with
you to a degree on that.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Yeah, but your
broader point though about the
withdrawal, look, in
Afghanistan, I think there are
pockets of Afghanistan where
people are grateful that the
United States went in
and got rid of the
thugs from the Taliban.
And girls can go to school.
And women are not living
in constant
fear of being attacked.
But then there are large parts
of Afghanistan where the
Taliban are still in control.
And there's the added hostility
of US night raids or
strikes that are happening.
And they're sort of getting
punched from both sides.
So I do think that when there's
a withdrawal from
Afghanistan, there will
be a mixed bag.
But at the end of day, I think
we have to look back and say,
what was the point
of any of this?
I don't know anyone in the
military today, guys that are
being tasked with fighting the
war, that think that it's a
good idea to be there.
I mean, most Americans supported
us going into
Afghanistan early
on after 9/11.
At this point, I think the
majority of Americans are sort
of like, what's the
point of this now?
Who are we fighting anymore?
AUDIENCE: I'll try
to make it brief.
First, thank you very much for
the fantastic reporting and
all this incredibly dangerous,
hard work you do.
And sort of related to that,
especially as you've done what
could be termed kind of exposes
or what would normally
be called just good
investigative journalism, you
talk about Blackwater and all
these people and the US
government and the drone strikes
and things where
people tend to, I think, believe
they operate sort of
above the law.
How much do you actually fear
for your personal safety,
aside from the people that are
dangerous that you normally--
JEREMY SCAHILL: Did
Jay Leno put you
up to this or something?
AUDIENCE: No, I don't
listen to Jay Leno.
JEREMY SCAHILL: No.
I'm just kidding.
No, he just asked me the same
question on a TV show once.
AUDIENCE: Oh, really?
JEREMY SCAHILL: And
it was weird.
AUDIENCE: Now I feel bad.
JEREMY SCAHILL: And it scared
my mom to death.
Why does Jay Leno think
someone's going to kill you?
I always get embarrassed when
people ask me that.
And I appreciate your
kind words.
But I was talking to a colleague
earlier today--
I mean, there are journalists
that are missing in Syria.
This young guy who was
a former Marine
named Austin Tice.
He's been missing in Syria
for over a year.
We believe that he's being held
by the Assad government.
He was a reporter for McClatchy
News Service.
Record numbers of journalists
are being-- one of the most
dangerous places on Earth to
be a journalist is Mexico.
Mexican journalists that report
on the drug cartels are
just being bumped off and
assassinated left and right.
Journalists in Somalia are
being murdered by various
sides of the fighting
factions there.
And I always get embarrassed
because I live in a nice
neighborhood in Brooklyn,
New York.
I live in Park Slope, the land
of lattes and baby strollers
and double wide baby
strollers.
And I get to come back.
And that's where I am.
And I know that I'm
safe there.
And so many of our colleagues
that are in these places, they
live in a constant
state of danger.
And I always try to recognize
their sacrifice because I
think they are the actual
heroes of all this.
It's why my book is dedicated
to journalists locked up for
doing their job or who died
in pursuit of the truth.
Because a lot of times
people like me--
I go on MSNBC.
And I talk.
And people know my name.
And I have a book on the New
York Times Best Seller list.
And it's like, what about
Abdulelah Haider Shaye, this
journalist who's in prison
in Yemen in part because
President Obama told the Yemeni
government he wants him
locked up for having exposed
a US missile attack?
I'm no Braveheart.
My colleagues in Yemen,
Somalia, Syria, Libya,
everywhere else, those
are the real heroes.
And we don't know their name
because they're not reporting
in English necessarily.
Or they're behind the scenes.
If I see Thomas Friedman quote
one more time his taxi
drivers, his concierge, I'm
going to go and shave his
mustache myself.
I'm so tired of the sort of
pontificating there because
there are real journalists
that do serious work.
And they get almost
no credit for it.
AUDIENCE: No doubt.
JEREMY SCAHILL: But thank you
very much for the compliment.
I appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Jeremy, I just
want to say thank you so much.
Everybody, if you could give a
round of applause for Jeremy.
JEREMY SCAHILL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY SCAHILL: Thank you all.
Thank you for the
people watching.
[APPLAUSE]